[Music]
[Sounds of a toy train rolling around a track]
[Boy:] Woo Woo! Woo Woo!
[Girl:] Faster, faster!
[Boy:] Can you make it go faster, Grandpa?
[Jim:] Well, we can try, but remember, we've got to
slow down on the curves.
[Boy:] Can you make it go still faster?
[Jim:] Still faster. Oh dear.
Fast, faster, the young just have to go fast, don't
they?
I should understand that after what happened,
how many years ago was it...40, 43, I guess.
When I was 21 I was ready to take the measure of
the world.
I was working on a surveying crew during my
vacation from state college.
It was hard work, but I was in a hurry to get ahead.
The opportunities made me want to stay on
rather than go back to architectural school in the
fall, and then another thing, there was Jennifer.
[Music]
She had tried as well as she could to persuade me
to finish school, but one day I asked Jenny to
marry me.
I said that I'd work hard, and I promised we'd be
happy together.
Did I keep that promise? I think I did.
We decided quickly and it wasn't a mistake.
I worked up to the job of field superintendent with
the company.
I remember my first day in charge of the crew, old
man McGovern saying we'll never bring the job in
on time.
We did.
The next year we had a son. Junior looked...I
guess all babies look that way.
I certainly remember 1917 and '18.
As an army engineer, I had another job that had to
be done quickly.
Then, I returned to Jenny and our son. We were all
together again.
I worked hard; I spared no effort, least of all my
own.
Time became a challenge to me; again and again I
won out over time,
and finished jobs ahead of schedule.
[Music]
May 14th, 1925 was a day that ended like any
other work day.
[Steam whistle blows]
Not an important date on the calendar but an
important one to me and my family.
[Music]
[Jim collapses]
[Jenny:] Jim, are you getting ready?
[Music]
Jim, did you hear me, Jim, what's the matter?
[Jim:] Just feeling tired, very tired.
[Jenny:] You've been coming home tired for
months now. Are you sick, Jim?
[Jim:] I'll be all right in just a couple minutes.
[Jenny:] I'm getting a doctor.
[Jim:] I was wrong, it wasn't a matter of minutes.
The doctor said I'd be all right in about a year.
There was no doubt about it, after all the medical
tests were made, he said I had tuberculosis.
I had to remain in the hospital for treatment, for
rest, complete rest for about a year.
The first six months to be spent on my back, in this
room resting, wasting time.
At night it was even worse.
I worried about my family. How would they manage
without me?
I felt completely helpless.
Slowly, too slowly it seemed to me, I began to feel
better.
The weeks and months passed. Then it was
spring.
When I went down for my periodic checkup, the
doctor showed me that the area of disease
was now quite small.
I felt as strong as I had ever felt, why couldn't I be
discharged now and go back to work?
The doctor said that the disease was still
dangerous
and that it was out of the question for me to leave
now.
Then he told me that I had to give up the idea of
ever going back to my old job, once and for all.
That was a tough blow.
He tried to soften it by letting me go home to visit
for a few days.
Every moment of my freedom was precious.
I didn't even stop to call Jenny.
I wanted to surprise her, wanted to see her face
when I walked into our home.
[Music]
The surprise turned out to be on me.
Jenny had been working. That meant little Jimmy
rushed off to school in the morning,
not seeing his mother until evening.
It wasn't fair to the boy nor to Jenny either, not so
long as I was able to do a day's work myself.
I had to make up for lost time. There was a job to
be done and I'd been hired to do it.
However, it was work for a healthy man and
whether I'd admitted it or not, I was weak, still sick.
[Music]
Once again, I was in the hospital.
I'd tried to hurry.
I'd gone too fast. Now the prescription was at least
another year, maybe longer.
For days, I felt terribly alone and depressed.
Neither the friendly old man who was my new
roommate nor the nurses could penetrate
the curtain of my helplessness.
Yet it was my roommate Pop who finally made me
realize that I must forget the past
and start over with a new life.
Pop loved to grow things.
One day in talking about his plants, I think Pop was
really trying to tell me something.
[Pop:] Plants certainly do good here, this begonia
my sister sent is blooming already.
[Jim:] Well maybe this is a fine place for plants, but
not for me.
I can't just lie here.
They say it's a year, suppose it's more?
[Pop:] I ain't one for wasting time, it's all just a
question of getting started.
[Jim:] What do you mean?
[Pop:] Say, looks like this thing's rooted.
Took its own time all right. Some decide to root fast
and some decide to root slow
and some just can't make up their minds.
It's all according to nature.
[Jim:] I begin to understand what he meant. I
realized that I too had to grow again.
I had to start a second life and I had help, for my
doctor was all things in one, surgeon, counselor
and friend.
He took me back to my college days, to my three
years of architectural courses.
Now, they suddenly offered the prospect of a new
life; I had found something to start with, something
to build on.
Soon I was well enough to listen to some sharp
criticism.
The doctor imitated the way I used to walk and
then he gave me some sound advice.
I've never forgotten his words.
Slow down to normal, slow down to normal.
This became the key to my new life when I left the
hospital, September 19, 1927.
I found a job in a busy architect's office.
It was a big step forward and I brought along a
whole set of new attitudes, including patience.
At least one of my coworkers didn't seem to
understand that I was completely safe to be near.
Like a number of people, he didn't realize that your
doctor won't let you go back to work
if you're liable to spread TB.
Of course, the doctor watched my progress
closely.
In the evenings, Jimmy and I would do our studying
together.
When I took the state licensing exam for an
architect's license, I really had to pass two tests.
In the middle of the exam an old habit came back.
I found myself working faster, hurrying in order to
finish ahead of schedule.
A moment later I caught myself.
What's your hurry Wilson? I asked. You've got
plenty of time. Slow down to normal.
I am proud, very proud of that piece of parchment.
[Music]
In the next few years I designed all types of
buildings, little and big.
In 1939, my son Jim got his license and came into
the office as a junior partner.
When Jim returned from the service in 1945 he
began to take on most of the work, not that I
couldn't put in a full day myself.
Regular checkups by the doctors proved that my
health was good,
but now I could afford to take things easier.
Then, one morning in 1950 we got an invitation to
submit a design for an exciting project.
Jim realized how much it would mean to me to
design a TB wing for the new hospital.
When do you get started, he asked?
Immediately, I told him.
But, I suppose in a way I got started the day I left
the hospital 23 years ago.
Now, I'd finished.
When the job was finally completed it turned out to
be the most modern tuberculosis hospital
in our part of the country.
It had operating rooms that reflected the latest
achievements in medical science
in the fight against tuberculosis.
Here in the laboratory, doctors and technicians
kept abreast of the latest developments
in anti-TB drugs.
Here was an up-to-date x-ray room with the latest
of equipment.
In this modern tuberculosis hospital patients had
an opportunity to retain old skills
and learn new ones to start their second lives.
I consider this the greatest achievement of my life,
so the day the hospital opened was the day I
retired from business.
Then there was only one name on the door, that of
Jim Jr. I didn't have to worry about my son,
I knew he'd do a fine job and besides, I'd been  promising Jenny a second honeymoon.
We went back to Niagara Falls of course, but it was
good to return to our children and grandchildren,
to the quiet excitement of peaceful surroundings,
to the fullness and expectations of my second life.
[Girl:] Can it go again, Grandpa?
[Boy:] It's not broken. We can fix it, can't we?
[Jim:] Oh, of course, all you have to do is get it
back on the track...and slow down to normal.
[Music]